[Music]
chuck yeah got another explainer for you
and you bought gary this time yeah well
of course
that means we're gonna put some gotta
put some sports spin on this one of
course
spin has a lot to do with sports so i i
you guys called me into this
gary
what what do you want me to do
[Laughter]
what are some things you thought you
knew but maybe you didn't and so here i
am what do you have for your assignment
doctor tyson if you choose to accept
substance what that is
and this tape will etc
there are some very very big
scientific names attached to things and
then all of a sudden you find they
appear
their theories their principles appear
in
places well you know what i never knew
that was the case
now if we took the
the great and the good coriolis
and then said to you
field goal kick
i think you would have a thought
i
indeed would and do
so but let's we should talk about the
coriolis force first of all okay it's
not really a force
in fact we officially call it a
fictitious force
it feels like you're a force if you're
in the middle of experiencing it
but it's not actually a force pureness
okay okay okay so
this is what happens if you try to move
in a straight line
on something
that's rotating
aha then your path on that rotating
object is not a straight line even
though you swear you're moving in a
straight line
okay
so so take for example a spinning
platter we used to call those record
players okay
oh nice you could so spin it you know
put it at 33 and a third rpm
and take them to a chalk
and start at the edge and make a
straight line to the spindle
if you do that and then stop the thing
and look at
what your chalk line did it will be this
curve
from the edge of the platter to the
center
right so if you are on that platter you
would say there's some force
pushing this chalk
at a direction that's to the side
this this is how you would interpret
what you saw
and so you would invoke you'd say there
must be a force
and in this case we would call that the
coriolis force
meanwhile there's no such force ac
acting on the system
so
that's that's what's going on there so
so this would happen to anybody trying
to do a straight line or any kind of
path on something that's in motion if
you try to do it on a on a a
merry-go-round
okay
uh you could try to walk in a straight
line but it's not going to work
right relative to the merry-go-round so
that's all it is you'll also look like a
drunk person yes yes i've tried it i've
tried it you tried it
but wait chuck it was stationary when
you
all right
so the perhaps the most common
invocation of the coriolis force
is that which forces
winds
on earth
to curve into storms
uh-huh okay so there's there's an air
you know air
moves
okay on earth's surface
but earth's surface is rotating with the
solid earth
so here i am
try and i see
a
a
low pressure system
and i'm a nice puffy cloud okay
and if i see a low pressure system
i'm going to go towards the low pressure
system because there's that must mean
there's a higher pressure behind me
and i get pushed into the low pressure
system okay and i'm going to make a b
line for it or cloud line for it okay so
there i am
but wait
if i'm going north to meet my low
pressure system
and i'm a cloud south of it we're in the
northern hemisphere now
wait a minute as i go north
i find myself overtaking the low
pressure system
because my sideways motion
is faster where i started from than
where the low pressure is
and we've done this before the equator
is moving a thousand miles an hour
sideways
and if you're up at uh at
northern florida or dc or in new york
you're moving slower from west to east
than the equator is yeah you're all part
of the same solid object yes
but
you complete one circle in the same
amount of time as folks at the equator
do and they travel the longer distance
to do it
so therefore you must be traveling more
slowly they must be traveling faster
than you here's the point
i'm a cloud birthed
near the equator
i'm going sideways a thousand miles an
hour now i start marching north i'm not
touching the earth i'm floating in the
atmosphere
and i see the the low pressure system
and i find myself overtaking it
and i end up veering to the right
and by the same token a puff of cloud
north of that low pressure system
it all it too wants to reach the low
pressure system
except it's traveling slower than the
low pressure sensor it travels it goes
south and it
and it and and it lags behind
so all the air migrating north goes
ends up ahead of the storm and all the
ir going south ends up behind the storm
you put all this together
you get a counterclockwise circulation
around the low pressure system otherwise
known as a storm
because the cloud carries moisture and
if you're a cloud magnet all right and
right
so low pressure systems are
nucleate storms for this reason
what speed do i need to do neil to
overcome a coriolis
instead of 33 in the third oh well i got
you i got you
78. you don't want the 78. oh yeah
you have some old farts there on the
other side of the video
so the point is
the storms have so much weather going on
in them because all the weather is
trying to get to the low pressure system
and the low pressure system is the
center of the storm
that's why there's rain at a hurricane
okay oh and by the way
do you know about the eye of the
hurricane
maybe yeah yep
well i'm not going to say something and
have you tear me to pieces am i
truck that sounds like a no right
right do you know what's happening well
i think i do so so the the eye of the
hurricane is completely clear yeah right
no rain and it's perfectly quiet okay
and
i saw a movie
called marooned
it was a 1960s pre-moon landing movie
but we knew we were headed there so we
start we the you know hollywood started
making movies about this so the
astronauts were marooned in space i
don't remember why and we got to save
them all right so there's another launch
vehicle that the this is in florida
florida like
likes hurricanes don't they okay yeah so
they're they're they're ready to launch
the rescue vessel because they're
running out of oxygen but they can't
launch it because a hurricane is coming
because then they'll put the other
astronauts at risk so everyone's giving
up hope on this rescue mission until
someone points out wait a minute the
path of this hurricane goes right over
cape canaveral
oh so
we can how about that so we can launch
right over cape canaveral
when all the weather dies down so i was
like nine years old or something i said
that's kind of cool and so from then on
i was highly intrigued by hurricanes
that this can happen
here's the problem uh the hurricane
would have ripped apart the rocket
before it got you got to get it from the
outside of the hurricane to the eye of
the hurricane oh no no no no so so it's
the the the the the spaceship is
attached to the gantry it's fine
it's fine and it's round so it's not
it's not like a it's not like a balloon
it's not like a building where it's
going to be ripped apart yeah no it's
aerodynamic it'll it's it's fine okay
okay it's fine for that for that purpose
all right we should all build houses
yeah
and will i be hurricane
i'm not gonna volunteer to test that
theory
there's probably some wind speed that
would knock over a rocket uh oh by the
way the rocket that they worried would
get knocked over in the movie the
martian
right that's why they left mark watney
on the ground right right so he's
probably dead we better take off now
before this dust storm on mars this
storm's going to kill us right right
right
so let's leave him give him up for dead
and of course he was alive
but
but
the atmospheric pressure on mars is 1
100th that of the atmospheric pressure
on earth
1 100th
so if you have 100 mile an hour wind on
mars
they ain't much air they're doing it
yeah it's like an infant going
yeah
yeah that's it so they could have so
easily waited and then saved martin's
ass but they didn't they just left that
boy to die anyway so so he was a
scientist so you know what he said
what he said y'all just left me
because you know i you you don't think i
know what the atmosphere of pressure is
or heroin
oh
you're not giving up i'm not going for
it i'm not going y'all left me and you
know it
because you tried to know right this
very pressure wouldn't have toppled you
over you know right yeah i don't want to
hear it all right so here's the thing
because all of this air has sideways
motion to the center of the low pressure
system it never actually reaches the
center
that's why it's clear in the center it's
a fascinating fact
okay that that's why it never actually
gets there all right so that's how you
get hurricanes if you repeat that
scenario for the southern hemisphere
then what you find is that the forces
operate such that the storm rotates in
the opposite direction so storms in the
southern hemisphere rotate clockwise
storms in the northern hemisphere rotate
counterclock when i say storms i mean
low pressure storms
by the way air circulates
the opposite way for high pressure
centers
but if
because the air wants to leave
it will still circulate but since high
pressure systems
repel clouds
no one thinks of them as a storm
but it's essentially a high pressure
storm have you ever been completely
cloudless days and it was very windy
yeah that's what you're experiencing
okay you're experiencing air escaping
away from the high pressure system
gaining speed relative to you on the
rotating earth
so yes you can have high winds with no
clouds because the clouds are not
collecting if they're not collecting you
don't have rain or storms or
or hail or anything they do call them
wind storms when they're when the winds
are high enough you can have them right
and they'll knock stuff over but not
because it carries precipitation that's
all
turns out
i'm watching a football game
i'm watching
it was like a quarter to six on a sunday
and i finished watching some show i
forgot no it was another football game
and i have a show coming on at six and
um and i'm channel surfing and i came
upon the cincinnati bengals playing
somebody was it who are the seattle folk
the uh the seahawks i think it was the
seahawks but it was definitely
cincinnati bengals okay
and right at that time i tuned in
it was a tie and the game ended
so they went into a full period overtime
okay now you know the rules i think
they've even changed since i last
memorized them but each team gets
possession all right and
if they score a field goal the other
team gets a chance to score a field goal
if nobody scores
with each possession
then it's sudden death okay
that's the state of this game at the
time in the 15 minutes that i watched
so
it's sudden death overtime at this point
cincinnati has the ball they're at the
50 50 yard 45 yard line plus 10 yards
or whatever
whatever is the hike with the kick they
had to make a 55-yard field goal
and if they make it it's for the win
if they don't the game continues but
they could win it on this kick so i'm
watching this
and the kick it goes up and it tumbles
this is where no one breathes okay in
the stadium nobody breathes and you see
the ball tumble
and it's tumbling and there it goes
and it hits the left upright
and careens in for the score
and the cincinnati bengals win and i
said wait a minute hold on
and i did a fast calculation it was
airborne for like three and a half
seconds something like that i did the
math i checked the orientation of the
stadium the stadium is oriented north
south and i i said oh my gosh
the cincinnati bengals for the win field
goal kick was aided
by a third of an inch deflection to the
right
yeah caused by the rotation of the earth
people lost their minds i tweeted it
people lost their mind people wrote in
and say
god help simpson
i know that he loves you
the earth hates me well because you know
from baseball if you take a a round
object
and hit it with another round object
all right a fraction of an inch
can make all the difference in how the
thing bounces away from it
right so you have a round bat hitting a
round ball a cylindrical bat but it's
still round in its cross-section hits a
round ball a fraction of its is a ground
out home run or a pop-out
okay same is true with a round football
hitting the cylindrical upright
so
i think that third of an inch made a
difference and you can ca that's how
much coriolis force operated in the 55
yards of the field goal
well the coriolis owes a lot of people
some money
because you know everybody who had money
riding on that game no you checking the
bets yeah they were just like how did we
find this coriolis now now just because
i'm an educator i i i i said the
rotation of the earth but i didn't
mention coriolis because if you label it
then people get distracted by the name
and it prevents them from understanding
the concept so i said from the rotation
of the earth well how does that happen
the next two tweets i said this is like
the coriolis force and then i mentioned
storms and this sort of thing
so now for all north-south oriented
stadiums i watch for this when that
happens
so there you have it coriolis for us on
storms and football games
and if putting chalk on
old-fashioned record players playing at
any speed at all chuck alright guys we
got to call it quits on the coriolis
effect why did you mention who the dude
was who first came up with it
my notes his whole name right gaspard
gustav
coriolis oh yeah he was totally
fictitious oh yeah
nobody would have that name in real life
well only his force is a fictitious yes
not him
all right uh he published a paper in
1835 with this analysis so this is still
relatively modern last couple of hundred
years yeah get the understanding of this
given how long we've been thinking about
the natural world
so anyhow uh that's it
for this
installment
of explainers
neil degrasse tyson here keep hooking up
[Music]